Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Raumzeit, dem Podcast von der ESA und dem DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute geht es ein weiteres Mal zu einem Exkurs in das Sonnensystem. Das Thema hatten wir schon hier vor ein paar Ausgaben. Die fünfte Ausgabe hat sich intensiv dem Thema der Planetenforschung gewidmet. Dort habe ich mit Ulrich Kühler gesprochen, in Berlin vom Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt, dem Institut für Planetenforschung. Und genau dort befinde ich mich heute wieder. Um ein zweites verwandtes Thema aufzugreifen, und dazu begrüße ich als Gesprächspartner Alan Harris. Genau genommen Professor Dr. Alan Harris. Professor erst seit Kurzem habe ich gehört.
Seit Juni 2010.
Seit Juni. Und ist da auch ein konkreter Lehrauftrag mit verbunden?
Das ist eigentlich ein Honorar-Professor, seine Ehre. Und stammt von der Queen's University of Belfast in Nordirland.
Man kann es vielleicht am Tonfall schon hören. Du bist nicht aus Deutschland, sondern?
Nein, ich bin Engländer. Ursprünglich aus Birmingham, Mittelengland und habe dann an der Universität Leeds studiert, habe dort eine Doktorarbeit geschrieben in Infrarot Astronomie. Astronomie war immer mein Hobby als Kind, meine Leidenschaft damals und das hat mich dann zur Uni geführt und dort habe ich Physik studiert. Es ist mir gesagt worden, Physik ist ein Fach, das ganz offen ist, das kann zu verschiedenen Berufen führen, aber auch Astronomie. Und ich bin dann weiter danach nach Deutschland gegangen, nach Heidelberg und dort am Max-Planck-Institut für Astronomie habe ich ein Postdoc gemacht, für drei Jahre wieder Infrarot Astronomie. Danach habe ich dann eine Planstelle in einem englischen Forschungsinstitut bekommen, das Rutherford Appleton Laboratory und im Rahmen eines Projekts, einer Mission für Ründgen Astronomie, das hieß ROSAT, der Hauptspieler in dieser Mission war Deutschland, aber England und die USA hatten auch wichtige Rollen und ich bin als britischer Vertreter sozusagen nach Garching bei München gegangen zum Max-Planck-Institut für Extraterrestrische Physik und habe drei Jahre dort im Rahmen des ROSAT-Projekts verbracht und während dieser Zeit habe ich viel Kontakt mit dem DLR damals, der DFVLR, gehabt, weil das damalige war für den Betrieb von ROSAT zuständig und ich hatte da viele Kontakte und es war durch diese damalige Zeit, durch diese Kontakte, dass ich dann sozusagen rüber zum DLR gekommen bin und bin ja fast seit Seit 20 Jahren immer noch hier habe okay mein Fachgebiet jetzt etwas geendet, aber für mich ist das immer noch, die Astronomie ist immer noch eine leidenschaftliche Sache und ich bin sehr froh, dass ich in diesem Gebiet noch arbeiten kann.
Das Fachgebiet sind Asteroiden und Kometen und das soll auch bei uns im Mittelpunkt stehen. Aber vielleicht noch mal kurz Infrarotastronomie, Röntgenastronomie, wie kommt man überhaupt darauf, sich so früh damit zu beschäftigen? Wie alt warst du da, als du den Gedanken an Astronomie nicht mehr losgewonnen bist?
Ja, ich habe Interesse an Astronomie gehabt, schon seit ich ein kleines Kind war. Ich kann mich nicht an eine Zeit erinnern, als ich kein Interesse an Astronomie hatte. Ich hatte viele Fragen, habe sehr viele Bücher gelesen und es war ganz natürlich für mich dann später an der Uni, irgendwas in der Richtung zu studieren. Und es war damals, als in den 70er Jahren, dass die Infrared Astronomie sehr neu war, war sehr spannend und da hat man insbesondere Detektoren entwickeln können, die dann bereit waren für Weltraum-Missionen, für Weltraum-Teleskopen zum Beispiel. Und es war diese ganz spannende Entwicklungsphase, die Geburt sozusagen von der Infrared Astronomie, in der ich mich damals gefunden habe. Und mit Infrared Teleskopen kann man sehr viel im Universum studieren. Also alle Objekte strahlen im Infrared Bereich aus irgendwie. Und das gilt auch nicht nur für Sterne, nicht nur für Galaxien, nicht nur für Bereiche, wo Sterne geboren werden, sondern auch für Asteroiden, auch für Kometen, Planeten, alles, auch in unserem Sonnensystem strahlt im thermischen, wir sagen thermischen Infrared, das ist die Wärmestrahlung von diesen Körpern. Und man kann durch Infrared Astronomie sehr viel über diese Körper lernen. Und ich bin immer noch eigentlich in der Infrared Astronomie hier, weil wir benutzen hier für die Asteroidenforschung auch Infrared Teleskopen. Nicht nur am Boden, sondern auch im Weltall. Satelliten wie Herschel zum Beispiel. Auch Spitzer, das Spitzer Space Telescope.
Benutzen heißt, man kooperiert dann entsprechend mit denjenigen, die dort die Zeit vergeben.
Man gewinnt Beobachtungszeit. Man muss Anträge schreiben, man muss beweisen, dass man gute Ideen hat, dass die vielversprechend sind, dass die gute Ergebnisse versprechen. Und dann, wenn man Glück hat, bekommt man Beobachtungszeit auf diesen Teleskopen. Und das haben wir hier auch erfolgreich gemacht. Wir arbeiten natürlich im Falle von Herschel und Spitzer mit großen Gruppen von Wissenschaftlern. Nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern in Amerika, überall in Europa. Und bis jetzt haben wir sehr viele spannende Daten bekommen. Wir beobachten mit Herschel die ganz kalten Objekte, die am Rand des Sonnensystems sind. Nämlich die sogenannten Kuipergürtel-Objekte oder Trans-Neptunian-Objekte. Und mit Spitzer beobachten wir Objekte, die ganz nahe sind, sogenannte erdnahe Asteroiden. Und das sind zwei Populationen von kleinen Körpern im Sonnensystem, die ganz anders sind, die in ganz unterschiedlichen Bedingungen existieren. Und man kann sehr viel über die Geschichte des Sonnensystems durch Beobachtungen von solchen Objekten lernen.
Und die Röntgenastronomie, spielt die dann auch noch eine Rolle?
Nein, die Röntgenastronomie spielt für uns hier im Institut gar keine Rolle. Aber man kann dazu sagen, dass Kometen auch im Röntgenbereich beobachtet wurden. Es gibt bestimmte physikalische Prozesse, die dazu führen, dass Kometen auch im Röntgenbereich sichtbar sind. Aber ich würde das nicht als ganz großer Themenbereich der Astronomie bezeichnen.
Das heißt, Röntgenastronomie ist immer noch mehr für die Sternenbeobachtung wichtig?
Ja, meine damalige Aufgabe auf diese Mission war eher der Betrieb und die Auswertung der Daten, sodass man feststellen konnte, das Instrument arbeitet gut, liefert noch wertvolle Daten und ich habe mich ein bisschen schon mit der Röntgenastronomie damals befasst. Aber das war eher ein Zwischenschritt, könnte man sagen, in meinem Beruf, das mich dann zum DLR geführt hat.
Also die Infrarotastronomie ist quasi die wichtigste Technik eigentlich beim Erforschen von Asteroiden derzeit, wenn es nicht gerade eine Mission gibt, die direkt auf einem landet.
Es ist eine von vielen verschiedenen Techniken. Ich würde nicht sagen, es ist wichtig schon. Man hat aber auch andere Methoden, die wichtig sind, wie zum Beispiel im optischen Bereich. Da beobachtet man reflektiertes Licht, reflektiertes Sonnenlicht von Asteroiden, auch zum Teil im Infrarotlicht. Aber wenn man weiter zu längeren Wellenlängen geht, beobachtet man die thermische, die eigene Wärmestrahlung dieser Körper. Anhand von der Energie, die sie von der Sonne absorbieren, die haben eine bestimmte Temperatur, und die strahlen dann, also Infrarotstrahlung aus. Wie eigentlich jedes Objekt. In diesem Zimmer hier zum Beispiel haben wir eine Temperatur von um die 300 Grad Kelvin. Und da strahlen alle Objekte aus im thermischen Infrarotbereich bei einer Wellenlänge von ungefähr 10 Mikron. Und das ist genau in diesem Bereich, dass wir zum Beispiel im Falle von erdnahen Objekten arbeiten, die sehr nah bei der Erde vorbeikommen. Die haben ähnliche Temperaturen wie die Erde. Und deswegen zwischen 5 Mikron und 20, 30 Mikron bewacht sind wir dann Wärmestrahlung von Asteroiden.
Gut, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal so ein bisschen Begriffsklärung betreiben. Ich denke, der Begriff Asteroid ist ja allgemein bekannt. Nicht zuletzt wegen eines sehr erfolgreichen Computerspiels, was vielen Jugendlichen mal den Kopf verdreht hat und wahrscheinlich auch noch so einigen, die jung geblieben sind. Aber das ist ja ein sehr konkreter Begriff. Wo findet man Asteroiden und was sind Asteroiden genau?
Okay, Asteroiden befindet man eigentlich ziemlich überall im Sonnensystem. Es gibt aber ein, könnte man sagen, ein Hauptspeiker von Asteroiden, wo die meisten sich befinden. Das ist der Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel zwischen den Umlaufbahnen von Mars und Jupiter. Die Frage, warum gibt es ausgerechnet dort seine Anhäufung von Asteroiden, kann man so beantworten. Diese Objekte, die wir heute beobachten, sind Brückstücke aus Kollisionen von kleinen Körpern, die sehr früh in der Entstehungszeit des Sonnensystems entstanden sind. Das waren damals quasi die Bausteine der Planeten. Ursprünglich war das nur Staubteilchen, die zusammengekommen sind, die miteinander kollidiert sind. Und es hat sich auf diese Weise durch relativ sanfte Kollisionen, kann man sagen, hat sich kleine Körper aus Staubteilchen, Staubflocken gebildet. Und auf diese Weise sind die Körper gewachsen durch Kollisionen. Und nachdem so ein Körper eine Größe, ein Durchmesser von 1 Kilometer oder 10 Kilometer erreicht hat, dann spielt die Schwerkraft eine wichtige Rolle. Und es kann, wenn die Bedingungen günstig sind, mehr und mehr Material zu sich ziehen, dann durch die Schwerkraft und der Körper wächst und wächst zu einem großen Planet. Es kommt möglicherweise aber auch Phänomenen dazu, die bedeuten, dass es in vielen Fällen nicht zur Bildung einem großen Planet gekommen ist. Zum Beispiel, es könnte eine Kollision gegeben haben zwischen zwei solcher kleinen Körpern und das dann zu lauter Brückstücke führt. Es könnte auch sein, dass so ein Körper sich in einem Bereich des Sonnensystems befindet, wo es nicht so viele Staubteilchen gibt. Und dann geht langsam das Baumaterial aus und das Ding kann dann nicht weiter wachsen. Man vermutet, was da zwischen Mars und Jupiter passiert ist, ist, dass es gab solche kleine Körper, solche Bausteine, aber der Planet Jupiter ist schneller gewachsen und war sehr schnell, sehr groß, hat eine sehr, sehr starke Schwerkraft und hat sozusagen die Super da immer gerührt. Es kam durch die Gravitation, durch die Anziehungskraft von Jupiter immer wieder zu Änderungen in den Umlaufbahnen von diesen kleinen Körpern. Und anstatt von sanften Kollisionen gab es dann eher ganz zerstörerische Kollisionen, weil die relative Geschwindigkeiten von diesen Objekten waren, sind durch Jupiter erhöht worden. Und deswegen haben die, haben diese Körper sich gegenseitig zerstört. Es gab so eine Zermahlung anstatt, dass die Bedingungen gut waren für den Aufbau eines Planeten.
Also würde man jetzt zum Beispiel den Jupiter einfach wegbeamen, was nicht geht, aber wäre er zum Beispiel von heute auf morgen nicht da, wäre es durchaus vorstellbar, dass ich aus diesem Gürtel heraus über einen entsprechend langen Zeitraum sehr wohl auch wieder etwas zusammenführen könnte.
Ja, wir hätten dort dann gerade da zwischen wo Mars und Jupiter heute sind oder die Umlaufbahnen von den zwei Planeten, hätten wir einen anderen Planet. Durchaus. Und deswegen...
Der dann auch ein Steinplanet wäre.
Und es ist... Deswegen sehen wir hier in diesem Hauptgürtel ein Riesenanzahl von Asteroiden, die eigentlich fast alle Bruchstücke sind aus Kollisionen. Und das kann man an der Größenverteilung erkennen. Wir wissen durch die Theorie, was passiert, wenn zwei relativ große Körper so vielleicht 20 Kilometer, 100 Kilometer groß miteinander kollidieren. Wir wissen, was wir scherben es gibt, was für Bruchstücke, Fragmente. Und es gibt, man kann das theoretisch berechnen, eine bestimmte Größenverteilung. Und das führt dazu, dass es gibt sehr, sehr viel ganz kleine Objekte, aber nicht so viel große Objekte. Man kann sich vorstellen, man hat einen Teller und man schmeißt den Teller auf einen harten Boden, gepflichten Boden. Es bricht auseinander natürlich. Und dann aber, wenn man die Bruchstücke zählt, wie viel ganz große Bruchstücke habe ich, wie viel ganz kleine Bruchstücke habe ich, dann würde man so eine ähnliche Größenverteilung sehen. Und es geht runter bis zum Staubteilchen. Und davon gibt es sehr viele. Aber es gibt nur ein oder zwei ganz große Stücke. Zum Beispiel das größte Stück würde wahrscheinlich ungefähr die Hälfte der Masse des Tellers haben. Und dann zählt man immer kleine Objekte, Stücke, aber immer mehr in der Zahl, je kleiner man geht. Und so ist es mit Asteroiden. Und deswegen gibt es im Hauptgürtel einige ganz große Objekte. Es gibt eigentlich ein paar Objekte, die wahrscheinlich noch sozusagen sogenannte Planetessimale sind. Das sind ursprüngliche Planetenbausteine, die nicht zerstört worden sind, aber konnten auch nicht weiter wachsen. Aber es gibt dann sehr, sehr viel, Millionen eigentlich von kleinen Körpern. Und es geht runter bis zu Staubteilchen. Man hat da alle diese größten Klassen im Asteroidenhauptgürtel.
Wie muss man sich denn jetzt diesen Gürtel vorstellen? Also wie groß ist der? Was hat er für eine Ausdehnung? Wie lange muss man da durchfliegen? So als Raumsonde? Um ihn komplett hinter sich gelassen zu haben?
Man kann sich das so vorstellen, der Mars, die Umlaufbahn des Planeten Mars hat ein Radius von ungefähr 1,5 Mal der Abstand zwischen Erde und Sonne.
Also der astronomische Einheit.
Das ist die durchschnittliche Entfernung zwischen Sonne und Erde. Und 1,5 Mal hat man die Umlaufbahn von Mars. Und dieser Asteroidengürtel befindet sich dann zwischen 2 und 3,5 astronomische Einheiten ungefähr. Und dann Jupiter bei 5 AU.
Das heißt, er nimmt nochmal genauso den selben Weg ein wie von Mars zur Sonne. So viel Platz ist da sozusagen auf dem Gürtel belegt. Das ist ja eine ganze Menge.
Genau. Das ist schon ein Riesengebiet. Und ist möglicherweise für die Entstellung von Leben auf der Erde sehr, sehr wichtig, dass es diese Gürtel gibt.
Jetzt ist ja zwangsläufig, dadurch wie sich eben das Sonnensystem entwickelt hat, also am Anfang war halt viel Staub, dann hat sich die Sonne herausgebildet, um die eben auch noch diese Staubscheibe herum sich drehte. Das haben wir ja hier gerade in dem Planetenforschungs-Podcast ausführlich besprochen, aus dem sich dann eben die einzelnen Planeten herausgebildet haben. Dieser Asteroidengürtel ist jetzt übrig geblieben, aber alles ist ja im Wesentlichen auf dieser einen Achse. Alles bewegt sich mehr oder weniger flach auf einer Linie, auf einer Ebene, genau. Das gilt ja dann auch für diesen Asteroidengürtel. Also wie flach muss man ihn sich denn jetzt wirklich vorstellen?
Also so flach ist es nicht. Es gibt Asteroiden mit bestimmten Inklinationen der Umlaufbahnen. Im Hauptgürtel, durch diese allgemeine Drehmoment des Sonnensystems sozusagen, stammt aus einer riesigen Gas- und Staubwolke ursprünglich, die vor 4,5 oder so Milliarden Jahren kollabiert ist. Und vermutlich hat diese Wolke dann ein Drehmoment gehabt. Und diese Drehmoment befindet man wieder im heutigen Sonnensystem. Das heißt, die Sonne rotiert natürlich und alle Planeten rotieren in derselben Sinne um die Sonne. Genau wie diese ursprüngliche Gasstaubwolke. Und es kam durch die Fliehkraft und durch den Kollaps der Wolke zur Bildung einer Ebene. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Wolke so ungefähr swerig war. Das war ein sweriges Objekt, das damals kollabiert ist. Und aus so einem dreidimensionalen Gebilde hat man dann eine Ebene durch die Dynamik. Und deswegen haben wir diese ekliptische Ebene, wo alle Planeten und auch die Asteroiden in den meisten Fällen ihre Bahnen haben. Es gibt aber auch Kometen zum Beispiel, das sind Objekte, die sind ähnlich wie Asteroiden, aber die haben was dazu, dass die Asteroiden nicht haben, nämlich flüchtige Bestandteile. Kometen sind nicht nur steinartige Objekte, die haben vielleicht sehr viel silikatreiches, steinartiges Material, aber die besitzen auch einen Anteil von flüchtigen Materialien, wie Wasser, CO2. Kometen sind weit weg im Außenbereich des Sonnensystems entstanden, wo diese Bestandteile in festen Form waren, also Wassereis und CO2-Eis und so weiter. Und deswegen gab es draußen, jenseits von der Umlaufbahn von Jupiter, wo wir Jupiter heute befinden, gab es, waren die Temperaturen niedrig und es gab eine andere Art von Baumaterialien für Planeten, nämlich diese festen, soliden, flüchtigen Materialien. Kometen deswegen, wenn ein Komet Richtung Sonne kommt, gibt es Erwärmung durch die Sonneneinstellung und diese flüchtigen Bestandteile verdampfen. Und ein Komet bildet dann ein Koma und ein Schweif. Und diese Kometen haben zum Teil ganz elliptische Umlaufbahnen. Die sind von den großen Planeten beeinflusst worden. Und wenn es zur Begegnung, zum nahen Vorbeiflug sozusagen von einem kleinen Objekt, bei einem ganz großen Objekt wie Jupiter oder Saturn kommt, dann kann es zur drastischen Änderung in der Bahn, nicht nur Kometen, sondern auch Asteroiden können, zum Beispiel nah bei Jupiter vorbeifliegen. Und dann endet sich starkartig die Umlaufbahn. Und das kann zu hohen Inklinationen führen. Das heißt, dass dieses Objekt hat dann eine Umlaufbahn, die zum Beispiel senkrecht zur ägyptischen Ebene sein kann. Und das bedeutet, es gibt eine gewisse Verstreuung von kleinen Objekten im Sonnensystem, dass die nicht alle in derselben Ebene ihre Bahnen haben.
Ist das jetzt im Wesentlichen die Objekte, die nicht in so einem Gürtel eingefangen sind, sondern ihre eigenen Weg durch das Sonnensystem? Oder gibt es auch im Asteroiden-Gürtel eine Menge, die sich jetzt nicht da reinpressen lassen? Weil die müssten ja permanent auf Kollisionskurs mit dem restlichen Material im Gürtel sein.
Im Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel gibt es nicht so viel, die hohe Inklinationen haben.
Aber wie hoch muss man sich das sozusagen vorstellen? Also wenn das eineinhalb astronomische Einheiten sind, wo es irgendwie losgeht und bis dann mal nichts mehr kommt, wie flach ist diese Ebene tatsächlich?
Es ist ziemlich flach. Ich meine, wenn man von AU spricht, dann würde ich denken, im Wesentlichen ist es innerhalb ein paar Zehntel AU in beiden Richtungen, oben und unten. Nicht sehr viel. Ich meine, okay, dann hat man wahrscheinlich eine Verteilung. Je weiter man geht, desto weniger Objekte würde man finden. Aber es ist diese andere Population von Objekten, die ganz, ganz hohe Bahnen mit hohen Inklinationen haben.
Und was ist da jetzt los? Sind die dann im Wesentlichen auch alle mit derselben Geschwindigkeit unterwegs? Haben die sich alle schon so aufeinander eingespielt, dass das wie eine drehende Scheibe ist und alle bewegen sich gleich? Oder sind da nach wie vor alle in unterschiedlichen Geschwindigkeiten unterwegs und überholen sich permanent?
Die größeren Objekte haben schon stabile Umlaufbahnen wie die Planeten. Und heutzutage kommt es nicht mehr zu Kollisionen zwischen den ganz großen Objekten. Aber es gibt gewisse physikalische Prozesse, wobei die Umlaufbahnen von den etwas kleineren Objekten, also sagen wir zehn Kilometer und kleiner in Durchmesse, die die Umlaufbahnen von diesen Objekten allmählich enden können. Das kommt dazu zum Beispiel durch die Abstrahlung von Photonen. Photonen haben Momentum, haben Impuls. Und dieser Impuls hat eine Gegenwirkung auf die Umlaufbahn des Asteroiden.
Also wir reden jetzt von der Sonnenstrahlung.
Ja, genau. Sonnenstrahlung wärmt das Objekt auf und es gibt wieder diese thermische Strahlung, diese thermischen Photonen. Und über einen langen Zeitraum kann es zur Änderung in der Umlaufbahn von kleinen Mitgliedern des Asteroidengürtels geben. Das heißt, die bewegen sich. Die Umlaufbahn wird, der Radius wird entweder größer von der Sonne, das heißt die Abstand von der Sonne wird größer oder kleiner. Und das heißt, dass diese Objekte bewegen sich durch den Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel zum Teil. Und es kommt dann zu gewissen Umlaufbahnen, wo die unter den Einfluss von Jupiter kommen. Umlaufbahnen, die sozusagen eine Resonanz mit der Umlaufbahn von Jupiter haben. Zum Beispiel ein Objekt, ein kleiner Asteroid könnte dreimal um die Sonne kreisen, im genau denselben Zeitraum wie Jupiter einmal, nur einmal um die Sonne kreist. Und das heißt, dass diese zwei Objekte, Jupiter und den Asteroiden, kommen regelmäßig oder der Asteroid kommt regelmäßig unter den Einfluss vom Planeten Jupiter. Und durch die starke Schwerkraft von Jupiter wird die Umlaufbahn des Asteroiden langsam geendet. Das wird in der Regel mehr elliptisch und der Perihel-Abstand, das ist die Sonne, der nächste Punkt in der Umlaufbahn, wird immer kleiner. Und das führt dazu, dass das Objekt quasi den Hauptgürtel verlässt und findet seinen Weg in das innere Sonnensystem. Und so eine hoch elliptische Bahn kreuzt natürlich die Umlaufbahnen der inneren Planeten.
Das heißt, es gibt jederzeit die Möglichkeit, dass ein kleiner Asteroid aus diesem Gürtel herausgebuxiert wird, quasi im Wesentlichen durch den Einfluss des Jupiters.
Genau.
Also das ist sozusagen der Hauptgrund und sehr viele andere Gründe gibt es nicht.
Durch diese Effekte, wie ich gerade erzählt habe, von den Fotonen, die Emissionen von Fotonen und dann die Resonanzen der Umlaufbahnen mit Jupiter.
Ist das jetzt sozusagen hier im Institut, hat es dieselbe Aufmerksamkeit, die Asteroiden und die Kometen, betrachtet man das eigentlich immer gemeinsam oder sind das wirklich zwei vollständig unterschiedliche Bereiche?
Ja, Asteroiden und Kometen gehören in der Wissenschaft zusammen, aber die haben verschiedene, unterschiedliche Eigenschaften, die dazu führt, dass die Methoden, mit denen man diese Objekte beobachtet, studiert, sind nicht identisch. Weil zum Beispiel Kometen geben also Gase ab, die verdampfen, diese flüchtigen Bestandteile verdampfen. Man hat deswegen ein Koma und ein Schweif.
Was ist das Koma?
Koma ist diesen Bereich um den Kern des Kometen. Ein Kometen hat ein ein steinartiges Kern, sehr porös und aus diesem Kern kommen die flüchtigen Materialien durch die Sonnenerwärmung. Es bildet sich dann um den Kern eine Hülle, eine Gas- und Staubhülle. Durch das Effekt des Sonnenwindes und die Sonnenstrahlung kommt es dann zur Bildung eines Schweifs aus diesem Koma.
Der Koma ist sozusagen wie so eine kleine Atmosphäre.
Könnte man wohl sagen.
Eine Staubwolke oder eine Gaswolke, die sich aus den losgelösten Stoffen herumbildet. Die kann man dann auch sehen. Wenn man den Kometen anschaut, sieht man nicht nur den Schweif, sondern man sieht auch dieses Koma.
Das stimmt. Und deswegen, weil diese Koma-Bildung und der Schweif und die Tatsache, dass Kometen auch andere Bestandteile haben als Asteroiden, bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass die Spektroskopie eine sehr wichtige Rolle in der Kometenforschung spielt. Wobei man Spektrallinien bewachtet. Im Falle von Asteroiden gibt es dann normalerweise kein Koma. Ein Asteroid ist durch Definition ein Objekt, das aussieht wie ein Stern. Ohne Koma, ohne Schweif. Normalerweise. Es gibt Ausnahmen. Aber deswegen sehen wir keine Gase mit Asteroiden. Wir sehen aber Absorbtionsbanden. Das sind ganz breite Banden in Wellenlängen, wo der Sonnenlicht absorbiert wird durch die Oberfläche, durch die Materialien in der Oberfläche des Asteroiden. Auch wichtig für Asteroiden ist die Bestimmung der Größe, was bei Kometen sehr schwierig ist. Wenn man einen riesigen Koma hat und einen Schweif, sieht man den Kern normalerweise nicht. Aber bei Asteroiden, für die Asteroidenforschung, ist die Größe des Objekts sehr wichtig. Und das Albedo, das heißt, wie der Asteroid, wie die Oberfläche, wie reflektiv ist die Oberfläche, wie viel Sonnenlicht reflektiert wird, das sagt etwas über die Zusammensetzung des Asteroiden-Oberflecks aus. Und dafür braucht man andere Methoden. Insbesondere Infrared.
Aber wenn da jetzt auch solche Abstrahlung, also wenn da solche Bänder sind, die die Asteroiden absorbieren, dann geht man doch da eigentlich auch mit Spektrum-Mitri ran.
Genau, aber ganz andere Art und Weise. Mit niedriger Auflösung.
Und vielleicht nochmal die Begriffe ein bisschen, die auch so allgemein bekannt sind, ein bisschen rumzukriegen. Man spricht ja auch manchmal von Meteoren und Meteoriden. Was ist das im Vergleich zu den anderen? Ist das das selbe?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das sind Begriffe, die leicht zu verwechseln sind und normalerweise nicht richtig verwendet werden. Aber zunächst, wir fangen am Boden an. Meteoriten sind Brückstücke, die man am Boden findet. Ein Objekt, das man am Himmel biobachtet, ist kein Meteorit.
Es wird eigentlich erst eins, dadurch, dass man es findet.
Ja, genau. Aber ein Meteorit war mal ein Objekt, wie ein Asteroid oder Teil eines Objekts, der eine Umlaufbahn um die Sonne hatte, zum Beispiel. Ein Meteor ist ein atmosphärischer Phänomen. Ein Meteor ist ein Sternschnuppe. Und das ist normalerweise durch ganz winzige Staubteilchen verursacht, die dann ganz, ganz schnell in die Atmosphäre eintauchen und verglühen. Und man sieht diesen Streif am Himmel, nur eine Sekunde oder so und es verschwindet wieder. Und das ist ein Meteor. Das sind normalerweise ganz, ganz kleine Staubteilchen oder Staubkörnchen. Und es gibt auch Meteoriten. Das sind etwas größere Objekte, die Umlaufbahnen dann um die Sonne haben. Das sind eigentlich kleine Asteroiden. Man spricht von einem Asteroid ab einem Durchmesser von ungefähr zehn Meter. Wobei diese Größe von zehn Meter ist nicht so wichtig. Es ist eine Grauzone, was man Asteroid als Asteroid bezeichnet und als Meteorit.
Okay, aber es geht grundsätzlich darum, das Ganze ein bisschen fassbarer zu machen in seiner Relevanz. Und alles, was so unter zehn Metern ist, hat man gesagt, das ist jetzt für uns nicht mehr als Objekt wirklich so interessant, weil es einfach so wenig Auswirkungen hat. Aber wenn jetzt so ein Objekt in die Atmosphäre eintreten würde mit zehn Metern Durchmesser, das wäre ja schon mehr als eine kleine Sternschnuppe.
Ja, das wäre dann ein Feuerbau zum Beispiel. Und das erzeugt einen riesengroßen Licht am Himmel, würde sich sehr schnell bewegen. Die Nacht wird zum Tag für ein paar Sekunden. Und solche Feuerbälle werden regelmäßig beobachtet. Also auch über Deutschland ein paar Mal im Jahr sieht man solche Objekte. Aber so ein Objekt, 10 Meter groß, würde auf jeden Fall in der Atmosphäre fast völlig verglühen. Es würde vielleicht Brückstücke ihren Weg zum Erde finden, also feste Brochen. Und die würde man dann später vielleicht das Meteoriten finden am Erde, am Boden. Ab einem Größe von 30 Meter zum Beispiel. Dann wird es interessant, weil solche Objekte würden, ja es ist nicht bekannt, es kommt auf die Zusammensetzung des Objekts an. Zum Beispiel, es gibt solche kleine Asteroiden, die komplett aus Metall sind, Eisen und Nickel. Und so ein Objekt ist sehr sehr robust und kann den Weg durch die Atmosphäre überleben. Und das Ding könnte fast komplett mit seiner ursprünglichen Masse auf die Erde prallen und dann würde es einen Krater geben. Und das ist schon passiert. Wir haben in Arizona einen Krater mit dem Namen Barringer, oder Meteo-Krater auch genannt in Arizona. Und dieser Krater hat eine Durchmesse von 1,2 Kilometer. Und da man in der Gegend Eisen, Meteoriten oder metallische Meteoriten gefunden hat, hat man behauptet, dass das Objekt, das dort eingeschlagen ist vor 50.000 Jahren, war aus Metall.
Und hat man auch eine Vorstellung davon, wie groß dieses Objekt gewesen sein muss, um einen solchen Krater zu erzeugen?
Ja, also die Geschwindigkeiten bei solchen Aufschlägen auf der Erde sind recht hoch. Also zum Beispiel 10 bis 15 Kilometer pro Sekunde. Und um so einen Krater zu verursachen, braucht ein metallisches Objekt nur ein Durchmesser von 30 Meter zu haben. So eine Riesenmenge an kinetischer Energie, die dort ankommt.
Ich meine, das ist ja nicht der einzige Krater, der auf diesem Planeten gefunden wurde. Der Planet ist eigentlich übersät mit solchen Einschlägen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Erde trifft, oder trifft es alle Planeten im gleichen Maße?
Ja, Kollisionen sind grundsätzlich ein sehr wichtiges natürliches Phänomen im Sonnensystem. Wir haben schon erklärt, wie es durch Kollisionen zur Bildung von Planeten gekommen ist in der Flutzeit des Sonnensystems. Kollisionen haben durch die ganze Geschichte des Sonnensystems auf allen Planeten stattgefunden. Wir haben auch Beispiele, zum Beispiel Jupiter und der Komet Shoemaker-Levy 9, das war im Jahr 1994, in Jupiter eingeschlagen. Wir haben die Narben von diesen vielen Einschlägen gesehen. Der Komet ist auseinandergebrochen und es gab einen Einschlag nach dem anderen über eine Periode von vielen Stunden. Wir haben Beweise zum Beispiel auf dem Mond. Wenn man die Oberfläche des Mondes mit einem Fernglas betrachtet, da sieht man nur Krater. Der Mond ist komplett mit Kratern übersät. Der Mondoberflecke. Und die Erde würde genauso aussehen. Wäre es nicht für unsere Atmosphäre, die uns schützt, deswegen wegen Atmosphäre verglühen die meisten Objekte, die in die Atmosphäre eintauchen. Und die Erde ist geologisch sehr aktiv. Und es gibt Wetter, es gibt Witterung, es gibt Vulkanen, es gibt Erdbeben. Und die Oberfläche der Erde wird ständig erneut sozusagen. Und Krater verschwinden, Einschlagskrater auf der Oberflächen der Erde verschwinden in Zeitrahmen von Hunderten von Millionen von Jahren. Das sind nicht mehr zu sehen, nicht mehr zu finden. Und deswegen sieht die Erde etwas anders aus als der Mond, Gott sei Dank. Aber wir können auch auf der Erde bis jetzt fast 200 Einschlagskrater identifizieren.
Und die sind halt alle relativ jung?
Ja, junger als 500 Millionen Jahre oder so.
Und wie hoch ist jetzt sozusagen die sich daraus ableitende Einschlagsfrequenz? Kann man denn davon ausgehen, dass das so regelmäßig stattfindet? Oder ist das einfach Zufall? Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht müsste das ja schon eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit geben, mit der mit neuen Einschlägen zu rechnen ist.
Ja, also wie gesagt, es gibt sozusagen ein Fluss von Objekten, die aus dem Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel auf uns zukommt. Und ich habe gerade erklärt, dass es eine große, eine richtige starke Größenverteilung gibt im Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel. Je kleiner man geht in Durchmesser, desto mehr Objekte es gibt.
Klar.
Weil die Brückstücke sind aus Kollisionen. Diese Objekte kommen dann auf uns zu. Und gerade diese Größenverteilung sehen wir auch wieder in der Population der erdnahen Asteroiden, die möglicherweise gefährlich sein können. Das bedeutet, dass wenn man über Einschlagsrisiko redet, dann muss man die Größe des Objekts oder den größten Bereich angeben.
Für den man die Wahrscheinlichkeit haben will, ja.
Und das bedeutet zum Beispiel, wir können ein paar Beispiele geben, Objekte mit Durchmessen von mehr als ein Kilometer, die sind also sehr gefährlich eingestuft. Ein Einschlag von einem solchen Objekt würde globale Effekte haben. Und man recknet statistisch gesehen in Zeitabständen von ungefähr 500.000, 600.000 Jahren. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wenn es schon passiert ist, man kann 500.000 Jahre sicher leben. Weil das ist alles nur Statistik. Und es kann sein, es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber man kann eine Woche später schon wieder so ein Objekt haben. Es ist aber äußerst unwahrscheinlich, dass so was kommt. Es ist mal passiert, es wird auch in der Zukunft wieder passieren. Aber während eines Menschenlebens kann man das quasi ausschließen. Es gibt aber viele kleine Objekte. Zum Beispiel, wenn man runterkommt bis 20, 30 Meter, da haben wir Hunderte von Millionen von Objekten. Dann ist natürlich die Einschlagshäufigkeit entsprechend größer. Man würde sagen, mit einem Objekt von 10, 20 bis 30 Meter könnte man in Abständen von 100, ein paar hundert Jahren haben. Die sind natürlich dann für uns sehr interessant.
Um vielleicht mal die Gefährlichkeit noch ein bisschen besser einschätzen zu können. Also gut, 10, 20 Meter, das kriegt man mit. Dann gibt es ein bisschen Feuerball. Das hat dann vielleicht einer aufgenommen. Das landet bei YouTube, alle sind begeistert. Das hat man ja schon häufiger gesehen. Ein Kilometer wäre jetzt gleich globale Katastrophe. Aber wo fängt es denn jetzt von der Größe an, wirklich, sagen wir mal, vielleicht auch eine lokale Katastrophe zu sein? Also sind jetzt 100 Meter, sind da schon Städte gefährdet? Oder wo fängt es dann an?
Es kommt darauf an, natürlich, ob ein Objekt der Weg zum Boden überlebt. Und man kann ganz grob sagen, ab einem Durchmesser von 30 Meter, 50 Meter, je nach Zusammensetzung, könnte man erwarten, dass das Ding am Boden ein Krater erzeugt. Und dann wird es wirklich gefährlich. Weil wenn die ganze Energie runter auf einen Punkt kommt und es verursacht einen großen Krater, dann haben wir gesehen, in Arizona ist der Krater 1,2 Kilometer Durchmesser. Und wenn das mitten in einer Stadt wäre, das wäre eine totale Katastrophe. Es könnte sein, dass es die schlimmste Naturkatastrophe sein würde, die die Zivilisation je erlebt hat.
Zumal ja auch dann nach diesen 1,2 Kilometern ist ja auch noch nicht Schluss. Das dürfte ja dann auch so eine Art Erdbeben nach sich ziehen.
Ja, es würde natürlich viel Material in die Luft schleudern. Das kommt irgendwo anders in der Gegend runter. Man würde wahrscheinlich Erdbeben haben, auch in dem Bereich. Also okay, ich meine, normalerweise würde sowas keine statt treffen. Das würde wirklich seltsam, wenn man die Erdoberfläche betrachtet. Und die Tatsache, dass alle Bereiche auf der Erde dasselbe Risiko haben. Es gibt keine bevorzugte Region auf der Erde. So ein Objekt könnte natürlich auch ins Meer fallen oder in die Wüste runterkommen. Dann ist das also gar nichts. Wenn man dann weiter geht Richtung 100 Meter, da würden wir in Steitabständen von tausenden bis zehntausenden Jahren sowas erwarten. Dann 100, 200 Meter in der größten Klasse. Dann würde diesen Asteroid auf jeden Fall die Erde treffen, würde auf jeden Fall ein Krater bilden. Und das könnte sehr, sehr schlimm sein. Dieser Krater würde dann ein paar Kilometer in Durchmesser sein.
Aber auch nur, wenn er jetzt direkt aus Land aufschlägt?
Ja, klar. Wenn es aber ins Wasser kommt, dann hat man vielleicht ein Tsunami, eine Fluchtwelle. Und natürlich, man kann sich vorstellen, es gibt viele dicht besiedelte Regionen der Erde, die dicht ans Wasser sind. Zum Beispiel Kalifornien, Japan, überall.
Das hat man ja gesehen bei dem Pazifiktsunami, was das alles nach sich gezogen hat.
Genau. Und das ist durchaus eine mögliche Folge von so einem Einschlag. Aber es ist sehr schwer, vorauszusagen, wenn man so ein Objekt entdeckt, genau wann es einschlägt, wo es einschlägt und was die Folgen sein könnten.
Zumindest auf Jahre hinweg.
Ja.
Aber wann wäre man sich in etwa sicher? Also angenommen, man würde jetzt so ein Objekt ausmachen, was im nächsten Jahr mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auf die Erde eintreffen würde. Wie kurz vorher könnte man sich dann sicher sein, wo es auftrifft?
Man kann auch heute mit ziemlich Sicherheit sagen, dass, wenn ein wirklich gefährliches Objekt auf die Erde zukommen würde, würden wir das wahrscheinlich Jahrzehnten vorher entdecken. Es gibt ein Beispiel, nämlich Apophis. Das ist ein erdner Asteroid, hat ein Durchmesser von ungefähr 300 Meter und glücklicherweise wissen wir genau, dass Apophis die Erde nicht treffen wird, mindestens jetzt nicht bei seinem Vorbeiflug im Jahr 2029. Apophis wird aber sehr nahe der Erde kommen, in eine Höhe von ungefähr 30.000 Kilometer. Das ist unterhalb der Umlaufbahn von geosynchronen Satelliten. Das ist unser Hinterhof. Wir wissen aber, weil wir die Umlaufbahn schon gut genug, genau genug festgestellt haben, dass Apophis bei der Erde in diese Höhe vorbeifliegen wird. Wir sind nicht ganz so sicher, was danach passieren wird. Die Umlaufbahn von Apophis wird schlageartig von der Erde, von der Erdeanziehungskraft geendet. Man kann das auch ziemlich genau berechnen. Es scheint jetzt, als ob Apophis in den nächsten Jahrhunderten für uns, für die Erde, keine Gefahr stellt. Weiter wissen wir nicht. Wir können es nicht so genau in die Zukunft einschauen und die Umlaufbahn dann berechnen. Apophis ist ein Beispiel von einem Objekt, wo wir ungefähr zwei Jahrzehnte Vorwarnzeit hätten. Und auch, man kann sich vorstellen, die Umstände müssen nur leicht, ganz leicht anders sein. Und dann würden wir es mit einem möglichen Einschlag zu tun haben.
30.000 Kilometer ist natürlich für astronomische Verhältnisse nichts.
Gar nichts.
Das heißt, das ist Glück.
Wir haben Glück gehabt jetzt, aber wir können Apophis dann als Beispiel nehmen. Wir können sagen, okay, wir haben Suchprogramme. Es gibt verschieden einhandvoller Suchprogramme, die ständig Nacht für Nacht nach erdnahen Objekten, mögliche gefährliche Objekten suchen. Und die benutzen heutzutage ganz moderne Technologie. Die Teleskope müssen nur relativ klein sein. Wir brauchen keine ganz große Teleskope für die Aufgabe. Aber die Detektoren sind sehr, sehr gut, sehr empfindlich, sehr modern und vor allem die Software für die Entdeckung, für die Auswertung der Daten ist sehr, sehr raffiniert. Und diese Suchprogramme können weitgehend autonom arbeiten. Das heißt, die brauchen niemand, der ständig dabei sein muss. Und es werden jeden Tag Daten geliefert, die man dann auswerten kann und schauen, was für Objekte jetzt entdeckt worden sind. Das heißt, wir haben eine gute Chance, gefährliche Objekte sehr, sehr früh zu entdecken. Und das Problem ist aber zu sagen, okay, wie Apophis. Wir wissen ja, dass es dir bei der Erde vorbeifliegen wird. Aber es gibt immer noch eine Grauzone. Wir wissen nicht genau, wo Apophis sein wird. Es gibt, um seine Umlaufbahn sozusagen, eine gewisse Zone der Ungenauigkeit. Jede Messung in der Wissenschaft hat Fehlerbalken. Und auch die Messungen von Positionen von Asteroiden am Himmel. Und dadurch die Berechnung der Umlaufbahn hat auch Fehlerbalken und Ungenauigkeiten. Und das Problem ist so, wir würden wahrscheinlich hören, ja, es ist plötzlich ein Objekt entdeckt worden, könnte möglicherweise in 10, 15, 20 Jahren die Erde treffen mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 5%, 10% oder 20% oder mehr. Und die Frage ist dann, es wird sozusagen eine politische Frage. Sollen wir überhaupt was machen? Bei 10%? Ja, die Chancen sind gering. Das Ding an einem Durchmesser von 300 Meter wäre natürlich eine riesen Katastrophe, könnte ein Land wie Holland komplett zerstören, aber das Risiko ist gering. Nur ein paar Prozent, nur 5%, wir lassen das.
Holland könnte komplett zerstört werden.
Holland könnte komplett zerstört werden. Das heißt ein riesen Krater von 6 Kilometern oder so.
Das wäre so eine ganz neue Gracht.
Diese ganze Material verteilt überall. Es wird auf jeden Fall eine sehr schwere Katastrophe sein. Aber verbunden mit einer sehr geringen Wahrscheinlichkeit. Was macht man? Wo setzt man diese Hemmschwelle? Okay, 10 Prozent und bei 9 Prozent machen wir nichts. Bei 11, 12 Prozent unternehmen wir was. Wer entscheidet das? Diese Probleme sind nicht gelöst worden bis jetzt. Man kann sagen, wir haben schon mit unserer Technologie heutzutage die Gelegenheit, was zu unternehmen. Wir können mit ziemlicher Sicherheit Asteroiden ablenken. Wenn es wirklich drauf ankommt und wir wissen, die Erde ist in großer Gefahr. Ein Objekt bis hin zu 500 Meter, vielleicht auch mehr. Wenn wir ein paar Jahrzehnte Vorwarnzeit haben, dann können wir schon was machen. Und die Chancen sind relativ gut, dass wir während dieser Zeit das Objekt ablenken können, dass wir die Umlaufbahn enden können.
Kann es nicht auch passieren, dass der geostationären Gürtel ein paar Satelliten wegräumt?
Ja, das ist mal vermutet worden. Aber wenn man ganz genau die Dynamik, die Umlaufbahn anschaut und wo dieser Gürtel um die Erde gibt mit den Satelliten, man sieht, dass Apofis nicht durch diesen Gürtel fliegen wird. Es wird vorbeifliegen. Aber okay, in anderen Fällen könnte sowas passieren.
Angenommen, Apofis würde jetzt direkt auf New York City seinen Kurs genommen haben. Machen wir gleich mal das Hollywood-kompatible Szenario auf. Ist ja auch von Hollywood schon ausführlich gewürdigt worden. Mindestens zwei Filme, die dieses Katastrophen-Szenario beschworen haben und ihre eigenen Lösungsansätze präsentiert haben. Im einen Fall musste dann gleich eine Crew auf dem Asteroiden landen und ihn dann möglichst spektakulär sprengen. Was wären denn so die angemessenen Maßnahmen, von denen man sich heute sicher ist, dass sie auch was bringen würden? Und was sind die Maßnahmen, von denen man sich sicher ist, dass sie nichts bringen würden?
Okay, sagen wir, wir nehmen an, wir haben 15 Jahre Zeit. Und das Objekt hat eine Umlaufbahn, sodass es mit Raumsonden erreichbar ist in der Zwischenzeit. Das erste, was wir machen würden, ist eine Erkundungsmission zu veranstalten. Wir würden eine Raumsonde hinschicken mit Instrumenten. Wir interessieren uns für die genaue Größe, die Form des Objekts, die Oberflächenbeschaffenheit, die, wenn möglich auch, würden wir gerne Informationen über die innere Struktur haben, die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit, Orientation der Rotationsvektor, solche Informationen. Diese Informationen würden wir dann sammeln.
Aber würde es dann nicht sieben Jahre dauern, bis man ihm sozusagen auf halben Wege entgegengekommen ist?
Normalerweise würde so etwas vielleicht so lange dauern. Aber wenn es wirklich darauf ankommt und wenn wir uns organisieren könnten, das heißt verschiedene Länder zusammenarbeiten, die die notwendigen technischen Möglichkeiten haben, ich denke, das würde dann viel schneller gehen.
Also es geht schneller, um überhaupt erst mal was zu starten. Also man muss es natürlich erst mal erfinden und bauen und losfliegen lassen, aber dann ist es ja auch noch eine Weile unterwegs.
Ja. Vielleicht ein Jahr, paar Jahre unterwegs. Aber wir haben 15 Jahre insgesamt.
Aber wo fliegt denn dann dieser Asteroid? Also ich meine, der kann ja von irgendwo kommen. Der könnte der Erde entgegenkommen, der könnte der Erde hinterher fliegen. Da sind ja auch unterschiedliche Bedingungen jetzt für so eine Mission. Um wirklich dann auch da eine Raumsonde hinzubekommen, braucht man ja auch eine gewisse Konstellation von den anderen Planeten, wo man sich noch Schwung holt oder auf der eigenen Erde, um das sozusagen auch optimal zu erreichen. Das ist ja gar nicht gesagt, dass man da in einem Jahr hinkommt.
Oder? Im Falle von Apophis zum Beispiel. Apophis hat eine Umlaufbahn, die so sozusagen erdähnlich ist. Und deswegen kommt Apophis immer wieder bei der Erde vorbei.
Das gilt generell für alle Erdnahen?
Nicht für alle. Es gilt für viele. Insbesondere die, die die Erde bedrohen können. Wir haben sogenannte erdähnliche Umlaufbahnen. Und das heißt, das Objekt würde wahrscheinlich mehrmals bei der Erde vorbeikommen, bevor es wirklich einschlägt. Und dann haben wir ein paar Möglichkeiten, Gelegenheiten. Deswegen würde die Mission wahrscheinlich nicht so lang dauern. Und man würde sehr wichtige Informationen auf diese Weise gewinnen, sodass man wirklich eine effektive Abwehrmission veranstalten könnte. Und diese Abwehrmission würde man dann zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt starten, vielleicht in zehn Jahren oder so nach der Entdeckung. Je früher, desto besser.
Jetzt haben wir nur noch fünf Jahre.
Dann haben wir nur noch fünf Jahre. Und dann muss man wirklich eine große Kraft verwenden, aber diese Kraft haben wir in nukleare Sprengsätze, die wir in so einem Fall, wenn das Objekt relativ groß ist und die Vorwarnzeit nur zehn bis 15 Jahren, würden wir wahrscheinlich keine andere Möglichkeit haben. Dieser Szenario ist äußerst ungewöhnlich, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ein sehr großes Objekt, sagen wir 300 Meter, nicht früher entdeckt wird. Aber okay, nehmen wir an. Und wir würden dann in aller Wahrscheinlichkeit versuchen, mit nuklearen Sprengsätzen die Umlaufbahn leicht zu enden. Oder genug zu enden, dass das Ding dann bei der Erde vorbei fliegt.
Indem man das Ding jetzt springt?
Nein, Sprengen würde man nicht gern machen, weil dann hat man tausende Teile. Wenn man sicher sein kann, dass jedes Teil ein Durchmesser von unterhalb 50 Meter hat, dann verglühen diese Dinge die Atmosphäre. Das wird nicht so schlimm. Aber das kann man nicht voraussagen.
Da hat man wieder den zerbrochenen Teller. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass zwei, drei große Stücke übrig bleiben, die immer noch desaströs genug sind.
Genau.
Und die dann unter Umständen eine Bahn haben, die noch schlimmer ist oder die man vor allem gar nicht kennt.
Man würde wahrscheinlich dann zwei oder drei ganz große Einschläge haben, anstatt einen wirklich großen, sozusagen. Okay, man verteilt die Energie ein bisschen, aber es könnte sein, dass das schlimmere Folgen hätte als das Objekt selbst.
Also wo zündet man dann die Bombe?
Ja, das ist noch ein Thema der Forschung. Genau. Und es kommt darauf an, was die Zusammensetzung, was die Eigenschaften des Objekts sind. Aber wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Nähe der Oberfläche. Also wirklich nah dran. Der Punkt ist, dass es gibt natürlich im Weltall ein Vakuum. Also so ein Sprengsatz dort zu zünden hat ganz andere Effekte als auf der Erde mit Atmosphäre. Aber die Strahlung, die dabei erzeugt wird, würde sozusagen die Oberfläche zum Verdampfen bringen. Es wird seinen Düseeneffekt auf der Oberfläche verursachen, dass dann durch die Gegenkraft würde dann den Asteroid ein bisschen aus dem Weg bringen. Es würde die Umlaufbahn leicht ändern, die Geschwindigkeit leicht ändern. Das ist die allgemeine Idee, dass man versucht, einen Teil der Oberfläche zu verdampfen. Das funktioniert wie eine Düse. Das ist alles natürlich nur Theorie. Man kann sowas nicht proben. Aber es wird erforscht. Es wird sowohl in den USA als auch in Russland.
Da man sich ja nicht so sicher sein kann, was dann letzten Endes wirklich funktioniert, müsste man ja eigentlich auch gleichzeitig mehrere Strategien zum Ansatz bringen.
Genau.
Was könnten denn so andere sein?
Ein etwas wahrscheinlicher Szenario würde sein, dass wir, nehmen wir an der Podcast wieder, nehmen wir an, wir haben ein bisschen mehr Zeit. Und wir können anhand von Teleskopen auf dem Boden, sowohl als auch vielleicht eine Raumsonde, können wir relativ schnell die wichtige Information über die Eigenschaften herauskriegen.
Ich meine, für die Raumforschungsgemeinde wäre das ja sozusagen das Ereignis. Man könnte davon ausgehen, dass sich alle Teleskope, die nur irgendwie verfügbar sind, auf dieses Objekt ausrichten. Und es wahrscheinlich die best erforschte Himmelskörper aller Zeiten wären.
Ja, das stimmt auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn man ein bisschen mehr Zeit hätte, was, wie gesagt, mit diesen Suchprogrammen, und die werden immer besser, durchaus der Fall sein könnte, dann könnte man mit einem kinetischen Impaktor versuchen, die Umlaufbahn zu enden. Und das bedeutet, man startet eigentlich bloß eine große Masse, so groß wie man starten könnte.
Also mit den vorhandenen Raketen.
Ja, genau. Und das muss natürlich ein Navigationssystem haben, muss ein Triebwerk haben. Man muss das steuern können. Aber im Prinzip ist es nur eine große Masse. Einige hundert Kilogramm. Und man würde versuchen, mit so viel relative Geschwindigkeit, die man schaffen könnte, in den Asteroiden dann mit dieser Masse einzuschlagen. Und dieser Impuls würde, man kann es ausrechnen, dass es wahrscheinlich ausreichen würde, wenn man das richtig macht und wenn man die richtige Vorwarnzeit hat, lang genug, könnte man dann die Umlaufbahn des Asteroiden leicht umlenken, sodass es dann bei der Erde vorbei fliegt.
Sodass man ihn sozusagen wieder auf diese 30.000 km Abstand, die er jetzt sowieso hätte, dann wieder bekommen würde. Was heißt, man bräuchte etwas mehr Zeit? Wie viel mehr Zeit bräuchte man denn dafür?
Ja, es kommt drauf an, wie viel Masse in dem Asteroiden es gibt, wie viel Masse man starten kann, was die relative Geschwindigkeit ist. Zum Beispiel mit Apophis, wieder unser schönes Beispiel. Apophis kommt sehr nahe der Erde im Jahr 2029. Es gibt ein gewisses sogenannten Schlüsselloch. Das hat einen Durchmesser von 500 Meter, 600 Meter. Und es ist schon ausgerechnet worden, wenn Apophis durch diesen Bereich im Weltall durchfliegt, in der Nähe der Erde, wird Apophis dann im Jahr 2036 zurückkommen und die Erde treffen. Wenn wir aber vorab wüssten, dass die Gefahr, dass Apophis durch diesen Bereich, durch dieses Schlüsselloch fliegen würde, dann könnten wir im Jahr 2029 Apophis ganz, ganz einfach, ganz leicht zur Seite schieben, dass es nicht mehr durch dieses Schlüsselloch fliegt. Und dann würde Apophis im Jahr 2036 nicht mehr die Erde treffen. Der Fall ist so, dass wir sind...
Das heißt, das weiß man jetzt eigentlich noch gar nicht, oder?
Doch, man weiß genau, dass das nicht passieren wird. Das Apophis bei diesem Schlüsselloch wahrscheinlich in einer ganz großen Entfernung vorbeifliegen wird. Die Gefahr ist ausgerechnet worden und steht bei 1 zu 250.000 ungefähr. Es könnte passieren mit dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit. 1 zu 250.000. Das ist eigentlich sehr gering. Wir gehen davon aus, dass es nicht passieren wird. Wir werden auf jeden Fall in den nächsten Jahren genau das wissen, weil Apophis wieder beobachtbar ist. Wir können das auch mit Radar beobachten. Wir können die Umlaufbahn sogar genauer feststellen. Aber mit ziemlicher Sicherheit wird das nicht passieren. Aber wenn wir PEC hätten, dann wäre das die Gelegenheit, mit relativ geringer Kraft Apophis aus dem Weg zu schieben, sodass es im Jahr 2036 nicht mehr die Erde treffen würde. Das ist ein Beispiel von diesem Dynamik, dieses Schlüssel-Lock-Phänomen, das es eigentlich oft geben könnte in solchen Fällen. Und das wäre unsere Chance, mit relativ geringer Kraft die Erde zu retten sozusagen.
Jetzt haben wir diese Einschläge der Asteroiden, die es ja gab und ihm auch immer wieder mal geben wird. Es gab ja einige größere. Und insbesondere gibt es ja diesen einen bei Mexiko. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob er eigentlich irgendeinen speziellen Namen trägt. Der Krater?
Der Krater ist der Chixilup.
Dem ja nachgesagt wird, dass er sozusagen die Dinosaurier, uns der Dinosaurier entledigt hat. Ist das, wie sicher ist da die Erkenntnis, dass das solche Folgen hatte? Und was war das für ein Asteroid? Also was für eine Masse ist da aufgeschlagen?
Der Krater, so weit festgestellt wurde, hatte ursprünglich ein Durchmesser von, ich glaube, um die 300 Kilometer. Und das bedeutet, wir wissen nicht, ob Asteroid oder Komet, aber auf jeden Fall ein Durchmesser von zwischen 10 und 15 Kilometer wäre notwendig, um so einen Krater zu erzeugen. Es ist umstritten, inwiefern diesen Einschlag zum Ende der Dinosaurier geführt hat. Aber die Theorie, ich glaube heutzutage mit der meisten Unterstützung, ist, dass es weitgehend zur Auslöschung der Dinosaurier geführt hat. Es gibt diese sogenannte K-T-Grenze. Das ist eine Schicht im Boden. Ein paar Zentimeter dick, wo man nur Asche findet. Als ob es ziemlich überall auf der Erde, oder in vielen Teilen der Erde gebrannt hat. Wälder und so. Das heißt, irgendwo gab es eine große Hitzequelle. Und diese Schicht in der Erde, man kann den Alter des Schichts herausrechnen. Und das ist ziemlich zeitnah, kann man sagen, an der Zeit des Einschlags.
Wie hat man den bestimmen können? Wie kann man sich sicher sein, wann dieser Einschlag stattgefunden hat?
Das kann man zunächst durch geologische Untersuchungen feststellen. Ich bin keine Geologe. Aber es gibt auch Datierungsmethoden, radioaktive Methoden zum Beispiel.
Also man kann sich da sehr sicher sein.
Man kann ziemlich sicher sein, inwiefern das wirklich alles gleichzeitig passiert ist. Das ist die große Frage. Und genau wann sind die Dinosaurier ausgestorben? Hat irgendetwas diesen Einschlag überlebt? Das ist die Frage. Es gibt Behauptungen, dass es auch tausende Jahre danach noch Dinosaurier irgendeiner Art gegeben hat. Ich bin da nicht der Experte. Ich kann das nicht beurteilen. Aber ich weiß noch, dass es große Diskussionen und große Debatten gibt über dieses Thema. Aber die meisten Leute gehen doch von aus, dass diesen Einschlag mindestens sehr viel dazu beigetragen hat.
Das heißt also, dass Asteroiden maßgeblich diese Evolution mit beeinflussen, dass solche Ereignisse auch über die eigentliche Evolution hinaus nachhaltig alles gefährden können, auch uns gefährden können. Ich meine, wenn wir sagen, alle 500.000 Jahre kommt halt mal wieder so ein Kilometerteil vorbei und kann dann ungeahnte Auswirkungen haben. So alt ist ja die Menschheit noch nicht. Seitdem das letzte Mal was runtergekommen ist, hat sich halt da so die komplette Menschheitszivilisation aufgebaut. Und wer weiß, vielleicht ist ja auch in der Lage, sich vorher selbst zu vernichten, bevor der nächste Asteroid vorbeikommt. Also es gibt ja jetzt diesen Bereich der Astrobiologie, der auch in der Öffentlichkeit in letzter Zeit viel Aufmerksamkeit erfährt, weil man sich eben einerseits natürlich auf diese Exoplaneten stürzt und schaut, was gibt es denn noch durch die neuen Beobachtungsmethoden. Werden immer mehr gefunden und man ist sozusagen auch den erdehnlichen Planeten so langsam auf der Spur. Jetzt sind natürlich die Asteroiden alles andere als erdähnlich und natürlich auch Teil unseres Sonnensystems. Aber was bieten denn die, also wie tot sind denn diese Asteroiden? Was kann man denn diesen Asteroiden jetzt in der Asteroidenforschung überhaupt noch, was kann man denn aussehen herauslesen, was vielleicht auch für diese neuen Fragen der Astrobiologie eine Rolle spielen können?
Asteroiden sind hauptsächlich gesteinsbrochen, silikat, reiche Objekte, wie Gestein, die man auf der Erde findet. Wir wissen aber durch Laboruntersuchungen, dass gewisse Meteoriten, die vermutlich von Asteroiden stammen, Aminosäuren enthalten. Das heißt, dass diese Körper tragen lebenswichtige Materialien mit sich. Asteroiden enthalten auch Wasser. Dazu kommen auch Kometen, die schon gut bekannt sind, dass sie flüchtige Bestandteile haben, auch viel Wasser. Die große Frage ist, wie ist es überhaupt zum Leben auf der Erde gekommen? Es gibt auch eine ganz große Debatte über, wo das Wasser, das wir heute auf der Erde haben, wo das hergekommen ist. War das vom Anfang an dabei? Oder ist das möglicherweise auch durch Einschläge zur Erde gekommen? Asteroiden und Kometen sind in verschiedenen Bereichen des Sonnensystems entstanden. Die haben deswegen auch verschiedene Bestandteile, je nachdem, was gerade dort vorhanden war, als die entstanden sind. Und man braucht wahrscheinlich für das Leben eine bunte Reihe von verschiedenen Bestandteilen. Man braucht Wasser zum Beispiel, man braucht gewisse organische Materialien. Man braucht auch natürlich die wichtigen Umweltbedingungen, Temperatur, Luftdruck und so. Und es kann sein, dass Asteroiden und Kometen sozusagen als Transportmittel agiert haben. Und dass die gewisse wichtige Bestandteile zu Erde geliefert haben. Insofern ist es durchaus möglich, dass ohne diese kleine Körper, dass es überhaupt nicht zum Leben auf der Erde gekommen wäre. Wir können auch wieder zum Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel schauen. Es gibt eine gängige Theorie, die überhauptet, dass es Objekte im äußeren Asteroiden-Gürtel damals waren, die auf die Erde kollidiert sind. Also kolenstoffreiche Materialien und auch Wasser zur Erde gebracht haben, als die Erde noch in der Entwicklungsphase war. Deswegen sind Asteroiden und Kometen für die Astrobiologie wahrscheinlich sehr wichtig, soweit wir im Falle unseres Sonnensystems feststellen können.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Modell der Blumenwiese und den Bienen. Die Planeten sind so die Blumen, die so herumstehen und die Bienen fliegen quasi von Blume zu Blume und tragen so die Botenstoffe und die Fruchtbarkeit.
Ich verstehe diesen Punkt, aber es gibt, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel weit draußen im Sonnensystem gibt es niedrige Temperaturen, das heißt, organisches Material kann sich besser überleben. Also in der Nähe der Sonne wird es durch die Fotonen der Sonne durch die Erhitzung zerstört. Und Kometen insbesondere sind Kältetrühe, die behalten alles im Tiefgefroren wie im Tiefkühlfach und können deswegen diese Materialien frisch zur Erde bringen. Das Ganze ist alles nur Theorie. Wir können nicht sicher sein, was genau passiert ist, aber wir können ahnen, wie es gelaufen ist. Wir sehen in verschiedenen Bereichen des Sonnensystems die Bestandteile, die man braucht, um Planeten zu bauen und dann Leben auf Planeten oder auf der Erde mindestens zu starten. Und es kann auch gut sein, dass es einmal Leben auf Mars gegeben hat. Weil diese Prozesse sind vermutlich überall gleich. Es ist nicht nur die Erde, die Einschläge erlebt hat. Wir wissen genau, Mars hat auch Einschlagskarte. Alle Planeten haben Einschlagskarte. Und obwohl die Bedingungen auf Mars heutzutage für das Leben sehr ungünstig sind, es kann sein, als es dort Wasser gab, wir sind sehr sicher, dass es einmal auf Mars Wasser gegeben hat, auch eine etwas dickere Atmosphäre, dass es durchaus möglich ist, dass es dort Leben gegeben hat. Es ist nur halt, dass die Erde ist, anscheinend, und nur die Erde hat genau die richtigen Bedingungen, dass es hier Leben wirklich etablieren könnte und lang überleben konnte. Ja, es ist schon wichtig, dass ein sehr wichtiges Thema der Astronomie ist extra solare Planeten oder Exoplaneten geworden. Wir haben festgestellt durch astronomische Beobachtungen, dass es andere Planetensysteme gibt, viele davon, hunderte davon. Es gibt glaube ich weit über 500 Exoplaneten, die bis jetzt entdeckt wurden. Und man fragt sich, könnte es dort auch Leben geben? Und warum nicht? Es hat sich einmal hier Leben entwickelt, warum nicht auch anderswo? Man vermutet, dass auch in anderen Planetensystemen Asteroiden und Kometen eine sehr wichtige Rolle spielen müssen. Wir haben auch Beweise bekommen, wieder durch astronomische Beobachtungen, dass es in einigen Fällen auch Asteroiden und Kometen in solchen Systemen geben muss. Wir können diese kleine Körper natürlich nicht direkt beobachten, weil die Systeme zu weit weg sind, aber wir können durch die Spektroskopie, können wir feststellen, dass es dort Staub gibt in diesen Systemen, genau wie in unserem eigenen Planetensystem. Und dieser Staub hat eine ähnliche, sehr ähnliche Zusammensetzung zum Staub, den wir in unserem eigenen Sonnensystem sehen. Also überall anscheinend gibt es ähnliche...
Wir sind nicht anders als sie.
Nein, das Universum, ziemlich überall, wo man hinschaut, sieht gleich aus. Und das gilt nicht nur für ganz, ganz große Entfernungen, wenn wir alle andere Galaxien anschauen, sondern auch in der Umgebung um unsere Sonne, in unserer Galaxie, sehen wir ähnliche Bedingungen, ähnliche Vorgänge und so. Und ich denke, es ist sehr, sehr wichtig, wenn wir Exoplanetensysteme weiter verstehen möchten, dann müssen wir aber auch unser Sonnensystem sehr genau unter die Lupe nehmen. Wir müssen hier ganz genau verstehen, was passiert ist. Wir haben wunderschöne Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten hier. Wir können mit Raumsonden hinfliegen zu Asteroiden und Kometen. Wir haben fantastische Teleskopen jetzt auch in Weltall, mit denen wir diese Dinge beobachten können. Und dann können wir unsere Kenntnisse, die wir in unserem Sonnensystem gewinnen, auch für die Erforschung von Exoplanetensystemen anwenden.
Was ist denn so jetzt im Bereich der Asteroiden- und Kometenforschung? Was steht denn so derzeit im Mittelpunkt? Wo sind die Fragezeichen? Was sind die großen Fragen, die man derzeit klärt? Oder ist eigentlich schon alles klar? Weiß man alles über Asteroiden und die Sache wird demnächst abgesetzt, weil man kriegt nichts Neues mehr raus?
Wir haben erst begonnen, diese Themen zu erforschen und diese Phänomene zu verstehen. Ich denke, wo es wirklich brennt, ist die Geschichte des Sonnensystems. Genau wie es dazu gekommen ist, dass zunächst eine Garstaubwolke kollabiert. Warum passiert das? Und wie entsteht ein Stern, die Sonne? Und wie genau haben Planeten sich in der Scheibe Staub, Scheibe um die Sonne gebildet? Und warum gibt es diese Anzahl von Planeten nur? Und warum sind die so groß? Und warum haben die gerade diese Umlaufbahnen? Und waren diese Umlaufbahnen immer so oder haben die Planeten ein bisschen hin und her gewandert? Man kann sehr viel erklären, wenn man sagt, okay, ein Planet wie Neptun oder so war nicht immer da, sondern fing irgendwo anders an und ist dann hinausgewandert. Es kommt dann wieder zu Resonanzen ab und zu und das bedeutet Kollisionen und Fragmente aus Kollisionen, die dann Einschläge vorsachen können. Es geht eher in der Richtung. Man möchte natürlich die verschiedenen Populationen von Asteroiden ganz genau untersuchen. Die TNOs, wie ich erwähnt habe, ganz weit draußen, spielen auch keine wichtige Rolle, weil die sind wirklich ungestört. Ursprüngliche kleine Körper, planetesimale, wie wir sagen. Und die sind so weit weg von den Einflüssen von den großen Planeten und von der Sonne, dass die sind, da können wir wahrscheinlich viele Fragen anworten über die Frühgeschichte des Sonnensystems, was gerade die erste Objekte, die sich gebildet haben und wie die zum Planeten gewachsen sind. Das Problem mit TNOs, mit diesen Käupegürtel-Objekten, ist, dass die so weit weg sind. Unsere Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten sind begrenzt oder die Information, die wir gewinnen können, ist sehr begrenzt. Wobei bei den erdnahen Objekten, da haben wir viel mehr Information. Und es ist eine Sache, wir haben auf der einen Seite Objekte, die weit weg sind, die sozusagen am Rand des Sonnensystem sind und Objekte, die quasi vor unserer Nase vorbeifliegen. Und wir müssen, es gibt Verhältnisse zwischen diesen Dingen. Und man hat auch die Hauptgürtelasteroiden, man hat auch Objekte, die zwischen diesen Bereichen sich bewegen. Und um das alles zu verstehen, um ein Gesamtbild des Sonnensystems und seine Geschichte zu bekommen, ich glaube, da wird im Augenblick sehr viel gemacht. Es sind sehr, sehr interessante Theorien, die erzeugt werden. Und immer wieder kommen überraschende Beobachtungen, die man nicht versteht. Es gibt wieder ein Rätsel und die Forschung geht weiter.
Gibt es denn Missionen, die so in Zukunft geplant sind zu Asteroiden oder Zwergplaneten, von denen man ausgeht, dass sie dann die Forschung auch entsprechend weiterbringen werden?
Auf jeden Fall. Es gibt auf der amerikanischen Seite einen Missionsplan, ein Proposal, Vorschlag für eine Mission zu einem Asteroid. Man würde versuchen, Material von der Oberfläche zurück zur Erde zu bringen. Es gibt auch auf europäischen Seite die ESA, überlegt jetzt, hat vor sich auch ein Vorschlag für eine ähnliche Mission mit dem Namen Marco Polo. Diese Mission oder der Vorschlag befindet sich gerade in einem Auswahlprozess. Deswegen ist es noch nicht sicher, dass diese Mission tatsächlich starten wird. Aber auf jeden Fall in beiden Fällen möchte man eine Probe von der Oberfläche, vielleicht ein oder zwei Kilogramm Materialien, von der Oberfläche zurück zur Erde zu bringen. Und dann hat man, was man dabei gewinnen kann, zum Beispiel, Einsicht im Verhältnis zwischen Meteoriten und Asteroiden. Wir haben auf der Erde in Museen sehr viele Beispiel von Meteoriten. Wir wissen aber nicht, woher die gekommen sind. Wir können, wir wissen, okay, es gibt eine Reihe von verschiedenen Sorten, von Zusammensetzungen. Und da draußen sehen wir auch, dass es viele Asteroiden gibt, auch mit unterschiedlichen Zusammensetzungen. Aber wir können die zwei nicht zusammenbringen. Wir wissen nicht genau, wo die Meteoriten hergekommen sind und wir wissen nicht, welche Asteroiden vielleicht Quellen gewesen sind für Meteoriten. Aber wenn man hinfliegt und man weiß, wir haben einen Asteroid, das ist sehr gut bekannt, wir haben das sehr gut erforscht und jetzt haben wir im Labor Materialien von der Oberfläche. Wir können dieses Material dann mit den Meteoriten vergleichen.
Was wäre denn so die Erwartungshaltung an diesen Fund? Was glaubt man denn da vermutlich zu finden und was wäre eine Überraschung, wenn man es dort finden würde?
Man würde sich natürlich für Wasser interessieren. Gibt es da viel Wasser im Gestein, verbundenes Wasser im Gestein?
Ist das wahrscheinlich?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Davon geht man aus. Insbesondere für diese Sorte von Asteroiden, das ist ein sogenannter C-Typ, das Ziel der Mission ist ein kohlenstoffhaltiges Objekt, mit einer dunklen Oberfläche. Da würde man nicht nur Wasser erwarten, sondern auch organische Molekülen. Das wäre natürlich auch sehr wichtig festzustellen, inwiefern Asteroiden organische Materialien enthalten.
Wie viele Typen unterscheidet man?
Von Asteroiden viele. Es gibt verschiedene Spektralklassen, die sind ursprünglich wie Sternen, anhand ihrer Spektraleigenschaften in verschiedenen Klassen zugeordnet. Die sind alle mit Buchstaben gezeichnet. Ein C-Typ, C für Carbon, Carbonaceous auf Englisch, das heißt Kohlenstoffhaltig. Es gibt auch S für Steinartig oder Silikatreich. Das sind die Objekte, die vielleicht weniger Kohlenstoff, weniger organische Materialien tragen. Und dann gibt es M, ursprünglich für Metallic und so weiter. Aber man hat jetzt 20 oder mehr verschiedene Sorten und es werden auch jetzt unterklassen, untergeordnete Klassen gefunden oder vorgeschlagen für die Benennung. Es ist ein bisschen kompliziert geworden. Ein Problem ist natürlich, man hatte am Anfang nur begrenzte Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten im optischen Bereich. Jetzt können wir auch im Infrarot zum Beispiel beobachten, mit sehr, sehr guten Spektrografen oder Spektrometer, mit sehr viel besser Auflösungen. Das heißt, wir können viel mehr Spektraleigenschaften beobachten, untersuchen. Und das führt dazu, dass diese ursprüngliche Schema eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich richtig nützlich ist, weil man jetzt viel mehr unterscheiden kann. Und wir müssen immer wieder dieses Ding ändern.
Aber diese C-Typen sind in gewisser Hinsicht erstmal am interessantesten, dass man die sich als erstes Ziel wählt?
Ja, das ist vielleicht eine Geschmackssache, aber ich glaube, die meisten Asteroidenforscher würden es so sehen.
Wie ist diese Verteilung dieser Typen? Also was ist sozusagen die häufigste Form? Gibt es da Erkenntnisse?
Ja, C und S sind wahrscheinlich ähnlich häufig. Es war noch was? S, Silikat, stony, silikatreich. Und die metallischen Objekte, es gibt wie gesagt rein metallische Objekte. Zum Beispiel der Krater in Arizona soll von einem metallischen Objekt verursacht wurden. Man kann sich fragen, warum gibt es rein metallische Objekte, die hauptsächlich aus Eisen und Nickel bestehen. Der Grund dafür ist, es gab ganz früh in der Geschichte des Sonnensystems, als diese planetesimale entstanden sind, kam es wie auf der Erde zu, man nennt das Differenziation. Das heißt, es gab eine Hitzequelle, vielleicht radioaktives Material mittendrin. Und diese Hitzequelle hat das Material des Objekts zum Schmelzen gebracht. Und die ganz schweren Elemente, wie Metalle, sind in die Mitte gefallen. Und das heißt, dass man Schichten hat von verschiedenen Materialien und die leichteren Materialien sind dann auf der Oberfläche geblieben. Asteroiden oder Planetesimale, die auch dieses Prozess erlebt haben. Wenn es dann zur Kollision zwischen zwei Objekten oder ein solches Objekt kollidiert mit irgendwas anderes, es kann sein, dass durch die Wucht der Kollision, dass das Ding auseinanderfällt und dieser Kern aus Eisen und Nickel wird freigesetzt. Das Ding wird total zerstört und der Kern wird im Wesentlichen freigesetzt als komplettes metallisches Objekt.
So wie so eine freigespringte Nuss, der Kern oder so eine Avocado, wo man das Weiche drum herum hat und das hat man dann entfernt und dann bleibt einfach nur noch dieser harte Kern übrig.
So ist es. Und man sieht, die sind selten, aber man hat schon einige Beispiele von metallischen Asteroiden entdeckt. Man kann es beweisen durch Radar-Bewachtungen. Man sagt, okay, wie kann man sicher sein, dass es Metall ist? Ich habe Radar nicht erwähnt. Radar ist eine sehr wichtige Methode der Untersuchung von Asteroiden. Asteroiden kommen zum Teil sehr nahe der Erde. Man kann ein Radarsignal hinschicken und das Echo empfangen. Dabei erfährt man sehr viel, nicht nur über die genaue Position, die genaue Umlaufbahn des Objekts, sondern auch über seine Zusammensetzung unter anderem. Es ist ziemlich gut bekannt, dass metallische Oberflächen sehr reflektiv sind. Deswegen durch das sogenannte Radar-Albedo kann man feststellen, es kann nur ein metallisches Material sein, weil das Echo sehr stark ist.
Im Asteroidengürtel gibt es ja auch noch so Objekte, die gerne mal ein Planet geworden wären, aber es irgendwie nicht so richtig geschafft haben. Ceres ist glaube ich das größte Objekt im Asteroidengürtel und lange Zeit als Planet geführt. Der Pluto, ich weiß nicht, kann man sagen, dass er auch schon Teil des Käupergürtels ist. Inwiefern nehmen die denn jetzt so eine Sonderstellung ein, oder sind das einfach nur die größten Asteroiden, die es gibt?
Ja, die sind auf jeden Fall die größten Asteroiden, also Ceres. Nein, Pallas, Veste nicht. Ceres ist der allergrößte. Und dann kommt Pallas. Und ich glaube, Veste ist Nummer 4 in der Reihenfolge. Und das Besondere an diese Objekte ist, dass die vermutlich keine Brückstücke, keine Fragmente sind aus Kollisionen, sondern sind eigentlich heile Planetasimale. Das sind Körper, die durch Kollisionen entstanden sind, gewachsen sind, aber wie gesagt durch das Effekt von Jupiter nicht weitergewachsen sind. Die haben das aber so weit überlebt und sind so weit gewachsen, dass wir wirklich fast kleine Planeten dort haben. Und deswegen sind diese interessant, weil wir haben dann vielleicht Beispiele wieder von der Frühgeschichte des Sonnensystems von Objekten, die damals entstanden sind, aber sich nicht weiter entwickeln konnten. Die sind auch sehr unterschiedliche Objekte. Wester hat eine sehr helle Oberfläche, ist aus, kann man sagen, geschmolzenes Gestein, ist einmal erhitzt worden. Wobei Ceres auf der anderen Seite ist ein dunkles Objekt, vermutlich reich in organischen Materialen, vielleicht auch Wasser, und ist wenig verändert worden im Laufe seiner Geschichte. Interessant ist die Tatsache, dass diese zwei Objekte, es gibt auch mehrere Objekte, auch die sehr unterschiedlich sind im Hauptgürtel. Aber wieso gibt es solche unterschiedliche Körper dort in diesem, in demselben Gebiet? Das wissen wir nicht. Es gibt vermutlich eine Mischung im Hauptgürtel irgendwie zwischen Objekten. Aber das Ganze ist nicht gut verstanden. Wir können von der Erde aus nur bedingt diese Dinge weiter erforschen. Zum Beispiel mit einem Hubble Space Telescope kann man Wester ein bisschen auflösen. Man kann ein paar Kraten auf der Oberfläche erkennen. Aber das ist alles ganz grob und nur wenig Pixeln haben wir da. Deswegen möchten wir gerne hin zu diesen Objekten. Es gibt schon eine Mission mit dem Namen Dawn, die gerade sich auf dem Weg befindet und wird bald Wester erreichen. Sie wird dort in der Umlaufbahn dieses Jahr noch um Wester gehen und da mehrere Monate bleiben, bis dann im Jahr 2012 der Flug weiter in Richtung Ceres. Und da soll Dawn im Jahr 2015, glaube ich, ankommen. Und wir hoffen sehr, sehr detaillierte Karten der Oberfläche, Abbildungen der Oberfläche.
Aber es ist nur ein Vorbeiflug im Prinzip.
Nein, es ist nicht. Die Sonde wird in Umlaufbahn um den Asteroiden gehen. Sie wird dort bleiben für mehrere Monate. Und deswegen gibt es die Gelegenheit sehr detaillierte Untersuchungen von der Oberfläche zu machen. Wir werden genau Details über die Zusammensetzung der Oberflächen bekommen. Auch die Form, die Struktur der Oberflächen werden wir ganz genau einziehen können.
Ist das überhaupt so einfach, bei so einem kleinen Objekt da in so eine Umlaufbahn zu gehen? Die Anziehungskraft dürfte ja nicht besonders groß sein.
Also die sind beide ganz groß genug. Da gibt es kein Problem. Für die kleinere Körper, also die Missionen, diese amerikanische Mission mit dem Namen Osiris Rex und Marco Polo auf der europäischen Seite, die ich erwähnt habe, als Ziel haben die beide erdnahen Asteroiden. Die sind ganz kleine Objekte, wie Apofis zum Beispiel, Durchmessen von mehreren hundert Metern oder so. Und da hat man doch Schwierigkeiten. Da muss man aufpassen, wie man in eine stabile Umlaufbahn kommt und dort bleibt. Und auf jeden Fall hinunterzugehen zur Oberfläche, um dort eine Probe zu nehmen, ist eine relativ schwierige Sache. Und da haben wir wenig Erfahrung mit dieser sogenannten Near Surface Operations in solchen Fällen. Und da muss man noch technologische Entwicklungen machen und man muss ziemlich sicher sein, wie man das machen möchte.
Das heißt, so mit dieser Mission Dawn steht eigentlich so der Asteroidenforschung ein richtiges Großereignis ins Haus dieses Jahr. 2011. Wann soll er ankommen? Ich glaube im August.
Ja, 2011, ja.
Und wie werden denn diese Informationen dann in der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinde gemeinsam bearbeitet? Stehen diese Beobachtungen dann auch sofort der gesamten Wissenschaftsgemeinde zur Verfügung?
In der Regel nein. Es sind gewisse Gruppen von Wissenschaftlern, die natürlich sehr hart, sehr viel für diese Missionen, für diese Mission gearbeitet haben. Und die sollen natürlich auch die die Früchte erben können. Die werden als erste die Daten auswerten können, werden die ersten Veröffentlichungen schreiben. Und in der Regel läuft es so, dass die über eine bestimmte Periode von einem Jahr vielleicht zwei Jahren bleibt, die Daten dann in Besitz der Wissenschaftler, die vielleicht ein paar Jahrzehnten für diese Mission gearbeitet haben. Danach werden in der Regel die Daten dann freigegeben für andere Wissenschaftler.
Das heißt, die unmittelbare Wirkung wird jetzt hier in Berlin nicht unbedingt zu spüren sein, aber man kann sich zumindest auf interessante Veröffentlichungen machen.
Wir sind aber hier auch daran beteiligt. Also das heißt, wir haben Leute hier, die Teil der wissenschaftlichen Themen sind und die werden auch entsprechend daran beteiligt sein.
Der Dawn fliegt dann weiter auch noch zu Ceres. Das heißt, man hat im Prinzip vielleicht zwei der größten Asteroiden untersucht. Geht man davon aus, dass die vergleichbar sind oder sind die schon sehr unterschiedlich?
Ja, die sind wie gesagt sehr unterschiedlich. Ceres ist ein eher kohlenstoffreiches Objekt, sehr dunkler Oberflecker. Deswegen von der Erde aus nicht leicht zu beobachten, weil es absorbiert sehr viel Sonnenlicht und Wester ist im Gegensatz sehr hell, hat eine sehr helle Oberflecke und dann auch nehmen wir an eine ganz andere Zusammensetzung. Also wir erwarten von den beiden sehr unterschiedliche Ergebnisse. Und vielleicht auch können wir langsam anfangen zu verstehen, warum es solche ganz unterschiedliche Objekte in demselben Bereich im Sonnensystem gibt.
Ja, jetzt gehen wir so ein bisschen die Fragen aus. Haben wir denn noch einen wichtigen Aspekt unbeleuchtet belassen, die man vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang noch unbedingt erwähnen sollte?
Ja, ich glaube wir sind quer durch das Sonnensystem gegangen. Sie haben auch ein bisschen über Exoplanetensysteme geredet. Es gibt natürlich sehr viele Fazetten der Forschung, die wir nicht erwähnt haben. Asteroiden mit Monden zum Beispiel. Es ist auch ein Phänomen, sehr interessant. Zuerst gab es immer eine Vermutung, dass Asteroiden auch Monde haben könnten. Planeten haben oft Monde. Aber ganz kleine Objekte wie Asteroiden, auch ganz winzige Objekte mit Durchmessen von 1 km oder so, haben zum Teil natürliche Satelliten oder Monde. Ich kann mich an eine Radar-Abbildung erinnern, wo es ganz klar und deutlich zu sehen ist, dass ein zentraler Körper einen Mond hat. Der um sich kreist. Man hat dann die Frage gestellt, wieso kann so etwas kommen? Weil so ein winziges Asteroid mit Durchmessen von 1 km hat quasi keine Schwerkraft. Und es kann unmöglich ein Objekt fangen. Man vermutet, dass zum Beispiel ein riesiges Objekt wie Jupiter oder Saturn hat seine Monde, die sind zum Teil auf jeden Fall gefangen. Objekte, die vorbeigeflogen sind und irgendwie durch diese große Anziehungskraft. Aber ein ganz kleines Objekt, 1 km groß, kann das unmöglich machen. Und es war die Frage, wie es dazu kommen könnte. Man hat am Anfang gedacht, okay, wir wissen, dass Kometen sich spontan auflösen können. Kometen sind sehr zerbrechliche, poröse Objekte und die verschwinden manchmal. Man erwartet einen Komet, der soll zurückkommen und er kommt nicht mehr zurück. Oder er kommt zwei Teile zurück. Wir wissen im Falle von Kometen Schumaker-Levy hinein, der in Jupiter eingeschlagen hat, dass das auch durch die Anziehungskraft von Jupiter auseinandergebrochen ist. Und man hat am Anfang gedacht, okay, dieser Asteroid mit Mond ist der Kern eines alten Kometen, der auseinandergebrochen ist. Aber wir haben von spektroskopischen Beobachtungen feststellen können, dass das überhaupt nicht möglich ist, weil Kometen haben ganz andere Spektraleigenschaften, als wir beobachtet haben. Und über die Jahre hat man eine sehr schöne Theorie entwickelt und es passt sehr gut zu den Tatsachen, die wir jetzt haben, zu den Erkenntnissen, die wir inzwischen gewonnen haben. Und es gibt ein Mechanismus, wobei Asteroiden schneller rotieren können. Es gibt sogenannte JORP-Effekt. Das hat auch wieder mit Ausstrahlung von Photonen zu tun. Aber in diesem Fall...
Schneller rotieren können als was?
Die Rotation wird beschleunigt.
Ach so, die wird immer schneller?
Immer schneller. Unter Einfluss von diesem JORP-Effekt. Das heißt, ein unregelmäßiger Oberflecker strahlt Photonen aus und die Kraft, die Gegenkraft, die erzeugt wird, ist nicht regelmäßig, ist nicht symmetrisch. Und das bedeutet, es gibt ein Torque, ein Drehmoment. Genau. Und wenn ein Objekt, das möglicherweise kein festes Objekt ist, sondern ist ein vielleicht der Produkt eines Einschlags irgendwann. Und daraus hat sich vielleicht anstatt ein robustes Objekt, ein einzigen Gesteinsbrocken, sondern ein Rubble Pile gebildet, ein Anhäufung von Gesteinsbrocken. Das gibt es auch. Wenn sowas rotiert, schnell, dann fängt es an, Materialien von der Oberfläche zu verlieren. Und es kann sein, dass ein großes Brückstück kommt weg durch die Fliehkraft. Und auf diese Weise kann man einen Mond erzeugen, sozusagen. Der Mond stammt vom Körper selbst.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, er spuckt sozusagen in kleinen Schritten das alles aus.
Und so kann man diese Tatsache erklären, dass auch solche kleine Körper Monde haben können.
Ja, spannend. Aber ich denke, jetzt können wir hier dem Thema auch erstmal ein Ende setzen. Vielen Dank, Ellen, für die Ausführung zum Thema Asteroiden und Kometen und was alles so um uns herumfliegt. Im Endeffekt wissen wir jetzt, wie wir den Planeten retten können, wenn es dann mal so weit ist. Man wünscht sich ja schon fast, dass mal einer kommt, oder? Das ist ja irgendwie so ein bisschen desaströs, aber was wäre das für ein Spaß der Menschheit, zuzusehen, wie sie sich dann endlich mal auf eine Maßnahme einigen kann?
Das darf man aber nicht sagen.
Nee, das darf man nicht sagen.
Das wünscht man sich nicht. Wir wünschen halt, dass wenn es doch so weit kommt, dass wir gut vorbereitet sind.
Ja, aber alle anderen Probleme könnten auf einmal unglaublich nach hinten treten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wenn so ein Eigentum eintritt.
Ja, das stimmt sicherlich.
Gut, das war's. Vielen Dank nochmal. Und vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören hier bei der neunten Ausgabe von Raumzeit, die nicht die letzte gewesen sein wird, sondern auch hier geht's wie gehabt weiter mit spannenden Themen rund um die Raumfahrt. Und ich sage Tschüss und bis bald bis zur nächsten Ausgabe.